I have to show you guys because it's too
funny this morning I woke up everybody's
dming me saying hey guess what she
deleted everything she said about you
etc etc but we saved it we have it don't
worry about it okay yes uh here so so
here's a okay let me just send you uh uh
[ __ ] I have to yeah I got all of them oh
fantastic oh yeah okay they send it all
right so let me send this to you this is
a girl named Nicole Arbor I don't know
who she is me neither man and by the way
she may be a very likable person she may
be somebody that's liked by a lot of
people that uh we like I don't even know
this I don't know who this person is but
she responded to my tweet Rob if you got
it just kind of pull it up and upload
that first and then we'll read this
tweet I don't want you to go to this
tweet yet I want you to first read the
tweets I sent you yeah so go go pull up
the tweet I sent you and and then I'll
tell you where I'm going with this if
you can pull this up okay go in so my
tweet that I read earlier you know the
one that I said don't know exactly what
happened with code but they have the
greater Thunder because here here's a
response go down she says uh uh not that
strange Patrick one is an American issue
and one is a multiple rape allegation
human trafficking and allegation that
have been going on since April and a
bucket of other possible charges in
Romania ask your friend Ina's Freedom
Cantor what he thinks about human
trafficking again I know nothing about
what she's saying here okay all of it
could be true okay so my response to her
is the following okay if you want to go
show the second one I don't know the
second one I sent you that I send you
two pictures get away from this one here
a Rob and go to the other one I sent you
I send you two pictures if you can pull
up the other one okay do you have it or
no yeah okay so the second one is
um
and you don't know this girl
period at all and in my job I don't know
who she is okay because I don't either
so then this is my response to her so if
you go to the bottom I said you sound
emotional yet certain
I'm choosing to be logical yet paranoid
but you also sound like somebody who may
have been attracted to him but he has
zero interest in you if that's the case
I'm sorry he hurt your feelings
meanwhile I'm waiting patiently to learn
more a troll level 100 by the way
straight up wait you're giving opinion
yeah and you're kind of trolling by the
way she's been responding to me and she
calls me you sound like a typical beta
male okay
and and she deletes that after she calls
me a typical beta male then I said the
following I said LOL I just realized
you're a comedian I can appreciate your
sense of humor but if I'm a beta male
wouldn't that make you an alpha female
no 40 years old single not married no
kids mic drop maybe there's a reason for
that sweet dreams my job and then and
then you see her tweet at the top yeah
she deleted it she deleted it so but the
point is the following the point is the
following
none of us know what's fully going on
everybody here could be wrong like if if
God forbids something happens all of a
sudden to this guy he goes to jail for
15 years you have to know people are
going to come after us and they're going
to be like oh my God you know you were
you gave the scattered platform you did
this and you're part of the problem as
well all this stuff they're going to say
yeah and then if the opposite happens
and he's out he's innocent you have to
also realize people are like I told you
you jump to conclusion so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]